♪
>> Will: WELL, TALK ABOUT
PERFECT TIMING TODAY GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO ANNOUNCED THAT NEW
YORK'S MASK MANDATE IT WILL BE
LIFTED ON WEDNESDAY FOR THE
FULLY VACCINATED.
NOW YOU ARE THINKING OKAY HE IS
FOLLOWING THE CDC A LITTLE LATE
LIKE HE WAS WITH APPROVING THE
VACCINE, GREAT NEWS BUT A LITTLE
LATE.
WAS HE FOLLOWING SCIENCE OR WAS
IT A DISTRACTION?
LATE TODAY CUOMO'S TAXES WERE
ALSO RELEASED REVEALING THAT HE
RAKED IN $5 MILLION FROM THE
BOOK HE WROTE ON THE COVID
CRISIS.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT NEW YORK
COLUMNIST AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MERANDA DIVINE.
MERANDA, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WITH ME.
SO HERE IS THE HERO, THE COUNTER
POINT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE
MEDIA AND THE LEFT'S HERO OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
AND NOW WE KNOW FROM HIS TAXES
HE PROFITED NICELY FROM THAT
IMAGE.
>> WELL, INCREDIBLY OBSCENE THAT
HE HAS MADE SO MUCH MONEY OUT OF
THIS, HE WAS WRITING A BOOK
WHILE PEOPLE WERE DYING, HOW
CALLUS DO YOU HAVE TO BE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE, IT IS YOUR FAULT
THAT 15,000 ELDERLY PEOPLE DIED
OF COVID IN NURSING HOMES
BECAUSE YOU ISSUED THE ORDER
THAT INFECTED PEOPLE SHOULD BE
SENT FROM HOSPITALS INTO THOSE
NURSING HOMES WHICH WENT AGAINST
ALL THE KNOWN SCIENCE.
WE KNEW THAT IN FLORIDA THAT
GOVERNOR DESANTIS DID THE
OPPOSITE.
HE MOVED TO LOOK AFTER THE
NURSING HOMES, ROOK AFTER THE
ELDERLY, PROTECT THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE MOST
AT RISK FROM COVID.
AND YOU HAD ANDREW CUOMO JUST
PUFFING HIMSELF UP ON TELEVISION
EVERY DAY BE GREAT AND THE GOOD.
TREATED AS IF HE WAS SOME SORT
OF A HERO.
AS YOU SAID, HE WAS THE
ANTITHESIS, SUPPOSEDLY OF DONALD
TRUMP WHO ACTUALLY WAS DOING
THINGS THAT WERE SAVING LIVES
LIKE ON JANUARY 31st, STOPPING
FLIGHTS FROM CHINA.
LIKE DOING THE BIG $12 BILLION
BET ON THE VACCINES SO YOU HAVE
ON THE ONE HAND A PRESIDENT
VILIFIED BY THE MEDIA FOR DOING
THINGS THAT SAVED LIVES WHILE
ANDREW CUOMO WAS DOING THINGS
THAT WERE ACTIVELY DEMONSTRABLY
KILLING PEOPLE AND NOW HE HAS
MADE $5 MILLION.
AND THAT WORKS OUT THAT BLOOD
MONEY, $100 PER DEAD NEW YORKER.
I HOPE HE ENJOYS IT.
>> Will: THAT'S A WAY TO PUT IT
AND SERIOUS FINE POINT TO PUT ON
THAT.
I BEGAN YOUR ANSWER SMILING,
MIRANDA, ONE OF THE BYPRODUCTS
OF THIS CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IS
PEOPLE WORK REMOTELY.
YOU AND I HAVEN'T HAD THE CHANCE
TO MEET.
I WILL FORGIVE YOU BUT I HAVE TO
TELL YOU I AM NOT SADLY DEAN
CAIN.
I'M WILL CAIN.
>> I'M SORRY IT'S WILL CAIN.
>> Will: IF I'M GOING TO BE
MIXED UP WITH ANYONE IT'S
SUPERMAN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> THANK YOU, WILL.
>> Will: I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY.
I TALKED ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES
AND PASSPORTS COMING SOON.
IT APPEARS IN NEW JERSEY THAT
COULD NOT BE FAR AWAY AS PHIL
MURPHY SEEMS TO HAVE GIVEN THE
THUMBS UP TO PRIVATE BUSINESSES
REQUIRING VACCINE PASSPORTS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, PHIL MURPHY IS, YOU
KNOW, SLIGHTLY WORSE THAN ANDREW
CUOMO.
HE HAS THE MOST PER CAPITA
DEATHS FROM COVID IN THE COUNTRY
AND ANDREW CUOMO HAS THE MOST.
I THINK PHIL MURPHY HAS BEEN A
SHOCKING GOVERNOR.
AND I FEEL SORRY FOR THE PEOPLE
OF NEW JERSEY.
IN MY VIEW, ANYTHING HE SAYS IS
WRONG.
>> Will: ALL RIGHT.
MIRANDA DEVINE, I WOULD BE FUNNY
AND CALL YOU TAMMY BRUCE BUT
THAT JOKE HAS ALREADY RUN ITS
COURSE.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, MIRANDA,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANKS, WIL